people
from long ago are able to predict
certain things it's uh
and it's almost like from long ago and
you've talked about this with uh with uh
uh pythagoreas
um
that
it seems that they they had a deep sense
of truth that's right permeates all of
this even even now so it's not just a
linear trajectory of an expanding
knowledge there's a deep truth that
permeates the whole thing yes so that's
how I see it actually I you know I gave
a talk about Pythagoras and pythagoreans
just a few weeks ago at the Commonwealth
Club of California in San Francisco
and because of that I did a kind of a
deep dive into the subject and I I I
learned that I actually totally
misunderstood Pythagoras and
pythagoreans that they were much deeper
than I thought
because you know most of us remember
Pythagoras from the from the Pythagoras
Theorem about the right triangles
we also know that pythagoreans were
instrumental in introducing uh the
tuning system for the musical scale
the the famous
um perfect fifth three halves of the uh
for the for the for the G for the soul
uh compared to the frequency of of Doha
or C you know and so but actually they
were
much more interesting so for them
numbers were not just clerical devices
you know that not kind of thing that you
would use in accounting only
they were imbued with with the Divine
and I cannot I cannot say that I I think
we lost it at least I have lost it I
look at numbers
and I don't really see that
the Divine the Divine that they clearly
did and so that
why else you know how else would you
explain so that in other words Divine is
of course is a term which is you know
it's been loaded so it's hard to
Escape that let's just say something
that more from the
world of imagination and intuition than
from the world of knowledge let's just
put this way
they were able to Divine okay abstract
that to intuitive
to Intuit that the the planets were not
revolving and the Sun and the planets
were not revolving around the earth they
were the first ones
at least in the western culture as far
as I know and in fact Copernicus
gave credit to pythagoreans as being his
predecessors
did you not quite have the the
Copernicus model with the sun in the
middle they had what they call the
central fire in the middle and all the
planets and the Sun were revolving
around
the central fire or Earth they called it
hurt
so but still what a departure from the
Dogma
from the knowledge of the era that the
Earth was at the center so how could
they come up with this idea
the reason was in my opinion that for
them the most movement of celestial
bodies was like music in fact we call it
musical universalis or Music of the
Spheres
for them the universe was this infinite
Symphony
in which every being you know humans
animals
but as well as the Earth and other
celestial bodies
were moving in harmony
like different notes of different
instruments in a symphony and so they
apply the same reasoning to the you know
the cosmological
model as they apply to the their model
of music
and from that perspective
they could see things
deeper than their contemporaries you see
so in other words they saw mathematics
as a tool
but that tool was not limited to itself
and it was they always they always knew
that there is more and they knew also
that every every pattern that you detect
is finite but the world is infinite they
actually accepted Infinity they believed
that Infinity is real
and if you discern a pattern
great you can play with it and you can
use that it gives you certain lands
through which to see
the world in a particular way which
could be beneficial for you to to learn
more and so on but they never had the
illusion that that was the final word
that they always knew that it's not the
whole thing so there is more there are
more sophisticated patterns that could
be discovered using mathematics or
otherwise
and I think that what happened was we
kind of lost this this other side of
their teachings we we took their numbers
and they're like idea that you could use
mathematics to discern patterns and to
find regularities and to explain things
about the world
we took that and we ran with it and we
kind of dropped the other idea that in
fact
there is a there is another side to it
which is kind of to us now
we say oh that's mystical but
what does it mean mystical if it is
something that helps you to make great
discoveries and the interesting thing is
that the people who are in touch with
the mystical Among Us
often seen as mad
and many of them are most of them are
well but not all of that none of them we
mentioned neospor and Newton and Albert
Einstein so but that's where the
conundrum is how do you find the balance
between the two so
the point I'm trying to make and you
know and this is what I feel
you know if you ask me what I find most
important thing today like what makes me
excited and enthusiastic and
passionate
is this idea
of balance
so you know
um
Nietzsche had this book wrote this book
in the 19th century called the birth of
strategy
and he presented this
Theory which I think is kind of very
useful
of these two sides of a human one that
comes from god Apollo
and that's our left brain so to speak
proverbal left brain so it's everything
has to do with that has to do with logic
and reason and analyzing dissecting
conceptualizing
and the other side which
uh comes from God Dionysus the an Isis
and that's responsible for intuition
imagination love
Geniuses was also god of wine
so it's also that side of
a human that makes us
sing and engage in in you know revelry
and
um and and drink wine and spend time
with friends and laugh and enjoy it you
know so Nietzsche Advocate at this point
of view that those were two
complementary sides of every human and
as well as Society
and
the purpose of human life
is to find balance between them
so math is
both discovered and invented we should
be okay with
having both ideas in our head and living
in the balance but more importantly for
me Apollo is like math and the anesis is
like love so yeah in in modern version
is love and math